morgen Grauen in Las Vegas Cameron
donarama ist längst unterwegs auf der
Jagd nach wasserverschwendern rund um
die Uhr patroulliert die Wasserpolizei
in Las Vegas denn hier darf kein Tropfen
verschwendet werden der Rasen darf
maximal 12 Minuten täglich bewässert
werden und das ist nicht alles
was stimmt hier nicht
sie dürfen jetzt Wässern aber das Wasser
darf das Grundstück nicht verlassen das
wäre Verschwendung ja das wäre ein
Regelverstoß
zunächst verwarnt Cameron die
wassersünder bei Wiederholung Folgen
Geldstrafen
Las Vegas liegt mitten in der Wüste 90%
des Wassers hier kommen aus dem Colorado
River und der trocknet aus
am legendären Las Vegas Strip Wasser
wohin man schaut
Wasserballett am Bellagio
Wasserfälle am Mirage aber der Name sagt
es schon es ist ein Trugbild denn Las
Vegas verkauft Illusion nichts ist wie
es scheint auch nicht der
Wasserverbrauch der verringerte sich in
20 Jahren um ein Drittel obwohl die
Bevölkerung sich verdoppelte
93% des Abwassers der Stadt werden
gereinigt und fließen zurück in den
Colorado River
patmaroy hat aus Las Vegas ein Vorbild
gemacht im Wasser sparen 30 Jahre lang
war sie die Chefin der Wasserbehörde und
eines wurde ihr in 20 Jahren Dürre klar
dieser Fluss wird nie wieder so sein wie
in den 60ern 70ern und 80ern
das ganze System baut auf reichlich
Schneefall und dass die reservoires sich
damit füllen und jeder neben kann was
ihm zusteht die Zeiten sind vorbei
Las Vegas ist nur wenige Kilometer
entfernt vom Hoover Damm und seinem
Stausee Lake mean der mächtige huberdamm
das Herzstück der Wasserversorgung im
amerikanischen Südwesten
die einlauftürme ragen einsam in die
Luft früher waren sie bis unter die
Brücken vom Wasser bedeckt
von seinem Stausee Lake meat aus werden
25 Millionen Menschen mit Wasser
versorgt die weißen Ringe sind die
Anzeichen der Krise sie zeigen wie hoch
das Wasser Mal stand
als es zurückging musste hier angebaut
werden jetzt haben Bootsbesitzer eine
lange eine sehr lange Anfahrt zum See
denn der Lake meat ist nur noch zu gut
einem Viertel gefüllt wo früher Wasser
war jetzt nur noch Dürre
wenn dieser Fluss austrocknet spürt
jeder den Schmerz
der Stamm der Chemie spürt ihn jetzt
schon
beschreiben eine Reise entlang des
Colorado Rivers der Heimat der Jeremy
[Musik]
obwohl sie am Fluss leben mussten sie um
das Recht Wasser nutzen zu dürfen lange
kämpfen
Blut das Südwestens ohne Wasser kein
Leben aber er wurde überbeansprucht und
vernachlässigt
sie möchten mehr Landwirtschaft
betreiben matt Sohn Danny zeigt uns ein
paar Bäume Granatapfel Zitrone ein
einfaches Bewässerungssystem macht es
möglich
einige Gewächshäuser werden gebaut noch
sind sie mehr ein Symbol der Hoffnung
denn es fehlt genug Wasser
97% des Wassers auf das die Jamie weevy
einen Anspruch haben bleiben im Fluss
der Grund dafür ist kaum zu glauben sie
haben nur eine einzige Pumpe um das
Wasser auf ihr Land zu befördern für
mehr reicht das Geld nicht
die Lebensader die alle Menschen
verbindet alle unsere Gruppen und
Mitglieder alle sind verbunden durch das
Wasser
letztlich steht der Colorado River auch
für Geben und Nehmen was allen gegeben
wird und uns genommen
300 Kilometer flussabwärts wird allen
gegeben Landwirtschaft so weit das Auge
reicht im Imperial Valley in Kalifornien
die abgezweigten Kanäle vom Colorado
River hunderte Kilometer lang machen es
möglich
um 6 Uhr morgens treffen wir Ronald
limegruber seine Großeltern haben hier
vor über 100 Jahren mit der
Landwirtschaft begonnen sein ganzes
Leben hängt am Wasser aus dem Colorado
River
[Musik]
ohne den Colorado River könnten wir
nicht existieren wir werden Wüste der
Fluss hat uns ermöglicht dieses Dürre
Wüstenland zu verwandeln in eine der
produktivsten Regionen der Welt
denn 90% des Gemüses das in ganz Amerika
über den Winter gegessen wird stammt aus
dem Imperial Valley dafür brauchen die
Landwirte aber auch besonders viel
Wasser
75% des Wassers aus dem Colorado River
fließen in die Landwirtschaft und die
Farmer kämpfen dafür dass es so bleibt
wir haben offizielle Dokumente die bis
ins 19 Jahrhundert reichen darüber wie
das Wasser verteilt wird wir haben
Wasser abgezweigt vor Los Angeles vor
Phoenix vor Tucson und sogar vor anderen
landwirtschaftsregionen unsere Rechte
sind den anderen übergeordnet und die
bekämpfen uns trotzdem weiter aber wir
waren beim Obersten Gericht und haben
gewonnen es ist eine Schlacht und wir
werden nie aufhören zu kämpfen
alte Dokumente aus dem 19 Jahrhundert
doch am Colorado River ist nichts mehr
so wie damals dennoch beharrt jeder auf
seinen Rechten Jugend
du kannst die ältesten Rechte haben das
ent wundervolle Stücke Papier hängen sie
dir an die Wand und bewundere sie jeden
Tag
aber sie werden komplett nutzlos sein
wenn kein Wasser mehr dorthin kommt du
hast die Wahl du kannst entweder Teil
der Lösung sein und an den
Verhandlungstisch kommen oder du kannst
Russisch Roulette spielen und dir in den
Kopf schießen du hast die Wahl
2026 werden die Wasserrechte neu
verhandelt keiner wird stur bleiben
können denn es geht um die Existenz
aller